now welcome to this video playing as oh
she again I just played them before
let's see what is playing against you
for ya busy grabbing a book not sure ok
so let's see a Sicilian let's play the
Russell you will not go for four main
line that I probably don't know yeah we
take see white usually place for a big
center against the set up with default
okay let's let's grab the center quite
often like is combining bc with night
age 6 f 69 f 76 he's not doing that is
some placing his pieces in a more
conventional way look so pretty solid
okay and it's let's do that get get back
the or make sure that he's not having
the bishop Pam should I play yeah d for
saying what what should i do should be
three maybe queen bee six
yeah probably the Queen needs to move
anyway from f3 it's not doing anything
red interesting
yeah maybe a good move just opening
opening up the position you can always
take and play that's in 95 which should
be really okay for black
yeah probably probably this is about
equal in jail 95 look so normal I don't
know maybe maybe why does still a bit
more comfortable for you look at this
year I've got maybe 95 coming and this
is this interesting intending to take
taken Knight f3 SSID em okay the root
comb wasn't doing much anyway on the
only one and maybe this is just not
helping him and now 95 is in the in the
position I mean 95 itself in itself is
not not decisive but it's still
something yeah maybe 95 you should be
six anyway we can even just get the
airport this is a bit uncomfortable for
black
hmm I'm not sure what black should do
maybe maybe just 97 retreat yourself and
and get this exchanged all night d5 go
but we'll go look Oh be 71 but why does
pattern why does patterns case camp is
so taking long time him
as he disconnected or something no yeah
is 661 the move that I also had had had
considered briefly I only thought that
probably found a foursome it's a very
committal news FYI he will play knight
c6
anyway knight c6 takes takes and then a
problem the knight on c6 is such a news
piece it feels like there should be some
kind of technical way to play nice what
is he thinking around okay
I thought maybe just just move it if ya
Quincy 3m that's it's it's really
threatening to win the night so and it's
hanging so if you would move it i also
have five but where do I where do I put
it on if I go nite eat we might play
Queen to be six maybe I need to go here
to prevent that if we now move the night
I I can maybe play Quincy 327 I know I
can play and I can play Queen c3
tracklist was was the the basic idea
yeah I need to move the night and I
thought Quincy dramatic and resigned
with this is 7pm Queen cool night here
and then I thought 2327 maybe Jack not
sure if it is the best way to play way I
can take any form it's not even not even
good okay this was my plan probably not
the best computer wants to play a
three-year look back like this one with
some advantage yeah maybe night a4
wasn't right I be 5v5 hospital of course
of course it's better i am just just
attacking this one and if he goes there
i can take ya and winning basically this
blacks falling apart this position where
you played e6 really was a bit
uncomfortable my idea 97's sir this was
what i suggested
it done yeah it's black hangs on but
it's very uncomfortable yeah somehow he
got into trouble I'm not sure that route
before really was so great around here
it shouldn't be any any big problem I
mean maybe maybe just just grab oops and
then this yeah come on this must be okay
for black he goes Knight f6 on something
I mean I probably won't treat here let's
let's go back then you can go here or
maybe Knight f6 okay yeah it's always
between equal end and a little something
for white alright thanks for watching